donc c'est bon est lo est lo du truc 30
secondes pour tourner vertical du truc
comme tu veux vertic on met
[Applaudissements]
vertic je
comess sur le côé mais on
[Musique]
pas c'est
vachement
60e
pr bien dans le black pr le noiras
toutes les belle forme voilà à gauche
voilà tuite que
l'hélicoptère pardon beaucoup plus vite
que l'hélicoptère là comment ça
[Musique]
je mvement je la freine la boule je sais
pas où tu es moi je sais pas tu je sais
pas où tu
es
j'ai l'impression que tu es un peu serré
peut-être dedans non attends on va je
sais pas où tu es
[Applaudissements]
là tu es devant là tu pas
je suis devant oui ah ouais tu es
vachement devant d'accord tu VO où tu es
tu es al là faut que tu t'écartes un peu
parce que c'est vachement beau ça va
arver c'est vachement beau voilà c'est
ça voilà voilà c'est super beau làdedans
tu vois voilà voilà
voilà voilà reste reste bien dedans là
pour bien les prendre reste un peu
là-dedans peut-être tu
vois
ah super super c'est magnifique
magnifique très
beau faille un peu sur ta gauche sur la
gauche il y a beaucoup de noir
maintenant
ou qu'on se décale un petit peu parce
que moi si je d ça va pas être
beau je vertic ça
[Musique]
arrive
ok noir dans tous les sens ça fait des
cercl tu pas c'est pas régulier
tout vachement devant pas vertical tu es
très devant to pas c'est bon c'est bon
c'est
bon al ça va être très beau par là
méit-toi ça va être très très beau le
sent deous nous là voilà là on passe en
dessous là en dessous la boule je pense
je pense que tu es un peu
serré
ah c'est super beau
ça un peu vers c'est bon un peu vers ta
droite attends voilà un peu vers ta
droite là maintenant mépie-toi ouis
c'est à droite que c'est beau hein voilà
pas pas vraiment droite voilà comme ça
làdedans c'est là c'est super beauin
partout là ça va tomberans tu vas
arriver ded voilà tu es là voil un peu
vers ta droite ça dev bon je sa pas pas
où tu
es voilà voilà c'est là où c'est beau tu
vois regarde les noir magnifi tu
vois super beau voilà voilà c'est là
c'est super magnifique
voil vers Tae à
gauche va à gauche va à gauche doucement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça une fois pour moi bien que tu unu ok
cé
OK pas contre jour fait dans le noir
noir je pense que c'est plus facile
ok c'est assez beau ça ouais c'est très
beau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
et ah non ser contre jour moi je le
verrai pas je fait chier je le verrai
pas on le fait contre jour tu veux le
faire non on va le faire de ton côté
allez tu le verras
contrejour si ça te va pour toi moi ça
me va
i ça va voilà regarde où c'est
[Applaudissements]
voilà regarde tu peux regarder par ta tu
vois bien
je voilà le contre jour arrive contour
arriveuche plus
derrière en travers contreour AR
contreour voilte un peu vers la gauche
du contrejour un peu plus jeille le di
par contre tu vois c'est vachement beau
là tu vois espèce
de sur un peuouais c'est beau ça voilà
reste comme ça voilà c'est très beau ça
voilà c'est
magnifique ti un peu oh la vache est-ce
que c'est beau ça le Goudon
là il Volut dedans c'est inoui là il y a
un truc qu'il faut que tu fasses là oh
la vache là faut le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça tu l'as eu tu l'as eu les couleur
incroyable
Volut a dégradé gris on le voit
bien je peux pas trop battre avec
[Musique]
le dans
[Applaudissements]
le le gris c'est incroyableè de c'est
l'au qui voit je
pense
alors là je sais pas où je suis parti
ouais ben tu tu es plus dans le
contrejour
[Applaudissements]
là es le contrejour est plus devant nous
que tu Remes plus faut que tu Remes
beaucoup plus tu so le goudron et tu le
remontes d'où tu es tu prends ta boule
et tu montes vers la et tu montes tu
montes vers nous tu remontes vers ta
droite tu vois là je peux pas trop
remonter
hein
[Musique]
VO et là quand tu vas suivre tu vas
aller sur un sur les bateaux avec les
les mecs si tu es voilà voilà en
continue problème c'est que le
contrejour est beaucoup plus devant
s'est déplacé vers le devant alors qu'il
était à l'arrière